d'accord ce que tu fais là je ne sais
pas tu fais quoi mais c'est pour ça que
je vous dis il faut reprendre notre
campagne est aussi question présent sur
le long terme et
je vous dis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait c'était un bon feeling pote
quoi un pote pas les bras mais tu avais
quand même envie de faire une un truc
avec quelques mois oui à la base oui à
la base oui et qu'après tu as envie et
qui s'est passé ce qui s'est passé s'est
passée ta vu italiens comme si tu
commandes d'une porsche turbo semaine du
goût
la villa
est ce que toi quand tu as vu tuân
il était conforme à ce que tu
t'attendais oui donc tu étais tu as fait
tu l'as bien aimé oui j'ai bien aimé
vous vouliez faire une idée digne la 42
ans annoncé l'histoire commencé un homme
c'est ça et qu'est ce qui s'est passé eh
ben le drame c'est à dire
en fait il a m'a carrément fait de
l'umih nation en public quoi en plus tu
dis et je louais la boit
oui mais c'est solide mais même si
j'étais marche en effet être dans le
vent la météo ça ne fait pas non
seulement sur ça c'est pas un mais deux
en plus c'est pas le cash de lien
envoyé des photos
filtré ok mais un jour je t'ai dis c'est
pas moi j'assume je mets des filtres
tiens je vais t'envoyer une vidéo je
suis juste maquillée de trois secondes
ou je te fais un bisou comme ça c'est ça
la vidéo
oui et après des photos maquillé mais
sans filtre mais quoi t'est venue de
quoi pourquoi je suis venu lui prêter
vue de ce pont sera baptisé hôtel et
donc c'est pas mon visage c'est mon
corps non il n'ya pas que le sort c'est
tout l'ensemble c'est lanta jamais vu
mon corps est à vue et tu mais ils
permettent encore si je les ai vus quand
tu es parti sur le plateau de thé ouvert
la porte j'ai vu là ton corps et à
l'investissement l'arrière et a posé
problème c'est tout l'ensemble je dis
sinon moi je suis très physique à ce que
ça donne le droit de langeais aucun
droit comme je te dis excuse moi je te
vexe ou pas mais comme je dis d'avoir
des opinions et avant les goûts et les
couleurs c'est ce que je pense mais quoi
tu as carrément à
tatiana
avec la ballade ça se fait pas ça se
fait pas non mais tu te rends compte un
peu moi tu as de la chance je suis forte
ouais mais une autre nana là tu peux la
détruire en deux camps aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que tu aurais à dire as-tu and
back texte un gros bâtard
il oublie de dire c'est que il ya eu
pire mais que m6 sa part voulu faire le
montage à cause du csa jeu m'a parlé
loupé montage s'il vous a dit il ma part
tu m'as parlé de cul c'était presse de
l'harcèlement sexuel non on revient
supérieur sur tu m'as tu veux que je te
dise comment il m'a dit toi tu as bien
de prendre des trucs dans le cul ça me
dit ça
parce qu'ils aiment prendre détruits
dans le
bricolage à la base qu'on peut dire
alors s'il vous plaît ça veut pas ça
c'est vraiment vraiment pas ils ont les
images et si je peux porter plainte je
peux récupérer les images c'est dans la
merde tu ne saches que là tu veux parler
comme ça avec
matthew moins deux ans il n'y a pas
d'âge pour parler comme ça va bien sûr
nations arabes ont alors jeté un brelan
il accepte le problème toi tu
te rends pas compte de la violence dit
oui tu dis mais comme il ya une
différence entre le penser le dire à la
personne et le dire à la personne devant
un million de personnes étaient là on en
rigole millions
débloqués il ya des gens qui sont
traumatisés par ça et souvent c'est pas
du tout contre vous mais souvent les
gens qui formule des attaques gratuites
et frontale sur le physique d'un leader
mais tu t'es vu toi jamais le nommer
l'homme il a raison
les gens qui y vivent réveille toi c'est
quoi un mois vas-y tu dis moi qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent c'est pas contre vous et
les gens je te rassure
franchement si elle était comme les
filtres et tout ça
mais je la voyais comme ça je la voyais
pas comme ça
ça veut dire jamais t'être est visé pour
les autres mettaient pas très physique
pour toi apparemment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors elle était venue nous voir une
fois et parce qu'elles vendent et
l'autre sont bas mais quoi 1500 euros
l'eau de votre bain vous la vendez
encore beaucoup pas franchement un mec
je pensais pas du tout que j'allais
avoir autant de commandes c'est
incroyable en ce moment je m'en met
plein les poches quoi ça
c'est incroyable de dire ça marco tu
quand elle elle vend l'autre sont bank
est on pense j'en connais un qui a envie
de l'acheter mais il n'a pas d'argent
ouais
vous comprenez airs et quelle bande
l'autre sont bons parce c'est un bon
business club et j'aimerais bien avoir
des fous cash et or ouais mais vraiment
des fous qui achète sa maman et voilà
demandez en moi une passion
presque c'est incroyable ils en sont
quand même année 500 euros sont venus
presque une profonde du malaise est réel
entrain de déléguer un peu mon travail
est vraiment jésus mais j'ai énormément
en finlande il a géré avec par jour
il arrive aux impacts a du mal géré à
moi les longs gants qui a moins la ville
d'avranches et hyper contente là avoue
la connerie surtout
c'est vrai
sergei que tu portes que cette idée
devant de l'eau de son bain toi qui
étais moi j'ai une question si c'est le
même bandits qui a
nancy il était au cagibi cela
qu'est ce qu'on pense d'eux ça toi
alors ça va tu suis un peu l'émission
est ce que vous vendez l'autre
l'autre athlète du pipi à l'intérieur
non sérieusement c'est sérieux oui je me
fait du bien dans le bain d'accord et
genre monsieur d'accord voilà d'accord
moi chacun son métier exactement tout
s'achète pardon où se vend tout s'achète
fabrice su comment ça que c'est fait ça
fait une polémique chasse est histoire
de l'eau de son bain ou pas franchement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un
combat de boxe entre deux influenceurs
dylan thiery et benjamin samat
et après un combat en trois bandes c'est
finalement benjamin qui a réussi à
s'imposer
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'équipe de tpb amiens unis caution ce
coup là j'ai des amis les papiers
vous habiller sur dylan ma couille
[Applaudissements]
benjamin pour l'instant il a un petit
peu de boulot belge
[Applaudissements]
voilà
deux ans que
cherchait le mode thani non mais dylan
qui s'est passé montre que les musées
j'aime bien benjamin aussi ouais et qui
s'est invité au camp il s'était très
bien entraîné et est vraiment très fort
un jeune un peu c'est estimer et 15
secondes après après le premier round je
me suis pété l'épaule à la planche et
direct fois je me suis battu avec la
main droite et je suis pas non plus
mohamed ali pour pour le battre juste
avec une main est content d'avoir fait
ça mais moi je suis très content ouais
ça reste du sport mais j'aurai ma
revanche et c'était aussi je me
contenterai pas l'épaule c'est vrai que
tu auras ta revanche bien sûr tu as
gagné commun m enfin parce que tu as
reversés à l'association se paye ni
combien danse avoir été payée mais après
je peux dire qu'il ya eu sept mille cinq
cents places devant du d'accord à
combien il y avait des places à 20 euros
à 50 euros à 100 euros est fière des
tables jusqu'à 40000 euros
je sais pas vraiment qui figure sur
cible il ya eu ça qu'on l'aimé ou qu'on
parte avec la table
[Rires]
il ya eu un petit peu moins de 5000 e
paper view vendus d'accord on dirait 40
irna c'est beau
c'est un succès ouais à un gros succès
gros succès ça je pense conséquent pas
donc tu vas faire ta revanche je peux
quand même temps tu te laisses juillet
juillet ouais alors surfer en juillet
avec plaisir je termine le ramadan je
termine de me guérir et donne à fond
alors et donc ouais donc tu es tu
faisais du ramadan gouët bien sûr bien
sûr ouais ça tu as été pas trop fatigué
j'ai eu le temps de couper ouais je vais
pas me couper ou d'accord parce que
c'est un que l'armé saisie il n'y a pas
des femmes qui veulent faire sa
détention si si si
il vaque s'échauffer s'arrêter là turner
rhodia qui est là vainqueur du combat
salut belgique
[Applaudissements]
bah
écoute bien des lilas son écharpe
franchement ça a été un outil et je sais
que j'y gagne il a le droit ça en
revanche à bravo que parce que bien sûr
il a porté ses
contrats nets chaîne tim spero sur le
ring de marseille est il en droit
d'avoir sa revanche surtout que c'était
vraiment un très très bel événement on a
kiffé eu comme moi non c'était beau de 8
mois puis bien évidemment pas bien sûr
mais mais mais franchement c'était
c'était trop bien trop bas excitant et
c'est l'une des premières fois depuis
des années des années qu'on réussit
rampling enquirer une salle anglaise en
france donc c'est tellement con qui pour
nous est en gros mission accomplie merci
[Applaudissements]
mercredi soir 20h20 champigny sur marne
un chien de race de type american staff
sans muselière va mort d'une jeune fille
de 16 ans celle ci parvient à prévenir
des policiers de la brigade
anti-criminalité à leur arrivée le chien
va s'attaquer à une deuxième victime
puis un policier face à la panique et
pour stopper l'animal plusieurs
policiers vont faire usage de leur arme
et tiré à sept reprises sur le chien
la vidéo filmée par un voisin fait
actuellement le tour d'internet et
certains dénoncent les responsabilités
des policiers alors images chocs d'un
chien abattu par la police ont-ils vu la
bonne réaction lorsqu'ils sont préparés
parce qu en loge était pas du tout
d'accord avec des fines raymond et
guillaume qui disait que la synergie les
lions qui disait que vous auriez pu
faire autrement à ce que vous auriez pu
faire autrement alors on peut souvent
c'est déjà plus facile de l'extérieur
faut savoir que la les collègues là le
chien reste surtout cette catégorie 2
chiens reste une arme par destination
bien sûr les collègues quand ils
interviennent ils viennent pas pour
faire un contrôle d'identité ils
viennent sur un avp corporelle ce
qu'elle arrive sur plate un accident
d'accord viennent pour un banal accident
une fois sur place ils constatent qu'à
une victime au sol qui est pris en
charge par les pompiers et les pompiers
explique aux collègues qui en fait non
cette victime a été mordue par un chien
d'accord il ya attaché de ce côté là
haut niveau comme vous pouvez le
constater la au niveau de la résidence
d'accord
et puis entre temps un individu du
quartier il vient il commence à s'en
prendre aux policiers ça tourne mal et
tout outrage rébellion interpellation le
chien s'énerve qui à proximité une jeune
fille de 15 ans ou 14 ans prend le chien
par la laisse est ici mais à la mordre
et là les policiers ils ont qu'une seule
alternative bien sûr c'est l'action et
c'est la légitime défense est en plein
dedans alors les deux ont été on connaît
pas exactement leur état mais les dons
été transporté par le samu à l'hôpital
mais c'est parce que je vous dis merci
la première a été mordu à la cuisse
gauche la seconde à la cuisse droite et
le chien ne voulait pas lâcher un jeu
précis on voit bien sur l'image mais ça
suffit de toucher une artère et tu vas
mourir en 5 secondes
et guillaume jan pas je pense par bon
mais qu'il ya d'autres solutions et
moyens à chaque année ça aurait fait
quoi toi moi ça m'est déjà arrivé quoi
tu l'auras on peut y a pas que les
troubles et on peut le tirer on peut le
moi je
suis d'accord mais entraînant alors en
dehors du chien sur le climat que
commente cette image on est dans un
climat de tensions sociales que tout le
monde a son flingue il est bien tard
mais
c'est ce qu'on disait dans la foulée
cambrioleurs fourbus dès qu'un problème
dès qu'un signe d'agressivité faut buter
grave
encore que tu fais là je ne fais pas tu
fais quoi mais c'est pour ça que je vous
dis il faut reprendre notre camp gbagbo
à l'émission ces questions réalisations
mais aussi ce
que je vous dis en entamant des
mobil-homes et ben ouais ça va être de
prendre les choses en amont oui mais
d'ériger réfute l'idée est sur le long
terme tu as souvent raison sur tel
raisonnement là il n'y a même pas de
débat est ce qu'on peut dire info une
fois une fois bravo la police bravo la
police est arrivée et là vous savez vous
raisonnez je tombe avec de la raison est
arrivé sur un terrain ou en 4 5 secondes
avec une décision pour sauver un enfant
n'y a pas de débat ils ont tué un chien
quand un chien tu attrapes des
cambrioleurs n'ont déjà parlé c'est qui
redoute plus une fois qu'il a très bien
fini il avait cinq secondes pour décider
pour sauver un gamin oui bravo la police
ils ont fait ce don du sang froid le
moment où le policier intervient au
moment où il tue le chien deux secondes
il met un coup de pied mais une belle
d'arrêt
je suis désolé c'est lé pa gorge de la
fille non mais j'aimerais qu'ils voient
là qu'on compte je pose la question dans
l'autre sens est ce que tu penses que la
vie d'un enfant la vie d'un chien je
pense que
ça a répondu oui moi ça me brise le
coeur de voir ces images je
ne dis pas que c'est bien qu'un enfant
hors jeu non à la question al-essaoui
vie d'enfant vous la vie d'un chien
un avait pas les bras
c'est bon c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais vous avez dans votre poche quelques
charmants j'aime beaucoup son humour et
son autodérision mais ces votants du
lendemain non c'est au sincèrement
[Applaudissements]
et
l'audi elodie c'est un incroyable et je
voudrais dire elodie je te jure côté
terne exemple je le pense vraiment c'est
un rayon de soleil c'est si tu souris
toujours
les téléspectateurs te connaître nos bus
raconte nous un peu ton histoire c'était
une histoire incroyable et elodie je
vous dis moi je suis fan absolu sont là
dort ici est un talent incroyable et
j'ai participé à un télé crochet je sais
personne je sais je sais pas je connais
un petit peu
c'est un petit peu dans le dur
on a un petit peu dans l'individu alors
j'ai sorti depuis deux singles
exactement grâce aux réseaux sociaux
grâce à l'amour des gens ça cartonne
pourtant et ça marche et ça marche c'est
bien sympa
j'ai fait 600 km bah oui c'est pas pour
un tout il faut les faire des
gaspillages sont le coeur un
pratiquement siriman baba mon nid
douillet avec toi j'aime sourire à la
vie car tu es doux comme une mélodie
peu importe nos différences et nos
chemins d'avant si avec toi je dansais
je vais dollar en
devient mon couscous
c'est enfin tu doutes je ne te dis
baisse pas les bras toi et moi pour la
vie on combattra l'ennui le soleil après
la plus haut
alors
j'attends toujours
merci merci et l'eau
sourire je connais beaucoup dans la rue
depuis avec passage au 20 heures oui
alors oui bah oui oui c'est vrai que
après je suis pas notre guide il a su
garder les 10
et 11 mai on reconnaît je fais des
photos et des jambes les gens sont
toujours super gentil donc dans la rue
ça se passe bien après sur les réseaux
des fois c'est un peu dur mais bon ça
même toit les raisons il ya du bon et du
mauvais il ya des gens sur les réseaux
qui te critique moi je parle bon matin
sont là bien sûr mais bon ça colle bon
mais c'est vrai car beaucoup de haine
aussi un serait vraiment pas des réseaux
et c'est difficile c'est assez difficile
si on est un peu fragile ou quoi ça peut
être ça peut être compliqué quand je
veux dire mais moi je supporte donc mais
abdou manque un petit peu de succès une
différence ces gens et certains cas où
est la différence quand il ya des gens
qui te t'attaques sûreté différence sur
les réseaux oui bien sûr c'est un gros
handicap ça différemment sur sur le
talent soucis mais pourquoi ainsi
pourquoi ça qu'ils trouvent à redire sur
tout
moi je crois le monde tout ça je prends
la monnaie et le reste ça me passe au
dessus quoi
si on me dit tu connais l'histoire de
marc côtoie
le roi de l'arnaqué c'est le roi de
l'arnaqué qui s'est fait choper ouais
ouais j'ai voulu me faire chopper parce
que j'ai regretté un petit peu ouais ben
il a ils haïssent été chopé il a payé le
prix gp
un jour j'aimerais bien savoir ce que tu
peux nous raconter marco n'aura que des
savoirs et beaucoup ont l'impression
qu'ils expliquent les non non attendez
c'est pas toi tu arrêtes de l'arn est le
rôle d'un bébé né se parler
sur l'année leur voyage riche je monte
pas d' arnaque le jeu moi je suis un
affairiste ça veut dire que c'est moi
après les autres seigneur je travaille
non une structure je travaille je
travaille et dès que je ne peux plus
m'en sortir jarnac jarlet pas je pense
que j'ai à prendre une survie ya peu
pape et sa survie passe janvier à 300
bars
et c'est génial pop up à savoir moi je
vole pas les gens voient la haye volet
moi je vole pas eh ben c'est notre
honneur à d'accord tu te plaît on fera
ya eu l'argent mais on m'a fait vraiment
payant mais c'est vrai qu'il a fait
nommer mais elle paraît dans les loges
tout à l'heure et là il a purgé sa peine
dans l'essentiel il est là ce soir
demandé ce que j'en pensais je pense que
quelqu'un qui a purgé sa peine ya plus
de débat exactement il ya purge accord n
points et en plus de ça j'ai purgé ma
peine mais ils m'ont mis des autres
affaires ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya une escroquerie maintenant
c'est marco mouly ah ouais
tu poster sous peu
à chaque fois la janais deux mis en
examen pour une affaire béghin say je
comprends rien ouais mais ça c'est non
mais le problème c'est qu'à 70 millions
parce que je connais la mode de béganne
sais pas ce que je fais ghinea desquels
oui c'est moi qui les a pris ouais c'est
moi qui a pris les 70 millions donc à
chaque fois qu'elle en a chaque fois qu
à une arnaque capable d'éviter ce sapin
est ce que tu es loin de cette arnaque
ou t'es pas trop loin
bien la vérité franchement
j'ai bossé on m'a donné d'argent
j'ai travaillé comme tu travailles comme
tout le monde travaille comme l'avocat
travail est bizarre j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas comme tout le monde
se soit complètement tout à fait commun
monde doit verser 10 à soi que c'est un
mec qui va au charbon et moi je te
respecte en tous cas matin inquiète pas
très envie qu'il est dans sa cheminée
tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]